I thought we could start where we left
off last session or where you and Gabe
left off last session talking about the
military commissions and your
participation in a military commissions
case so what was your first reaction
when you heard that Guantanamo detainees
were going to be tried by military
commission I mean I think my first
reaction to that and obviously that news
really came very early on so traveling
right was actually not even a lawyer yet
I was still a law student here at
Columbia and that was in November 2001 I
believe President Bush issued an order
creating the military commission so it
was purely a pure creation of the
executive branch of government obviously
that version of the Military Commission
is the one that the Supreme Court ended
up striking down in the hamadan case in
2007 actually 2000 and was at 2007 or
2006 66 thereabouts yeah so and that's
what led to the military commissions Act
of 2006 Soham that must have been 2006
and in the military commissions act you
have sort of the legislative branch
version of those military commissions so
my first exposure to the military
commissions was in 2009 when I was 2001
and I was still a student and obviously
at that point it wasn't really clear in
November of 2001 who would end up being
a defendant in those military
commissions it was sort of like the
structure that was created but you know
who would be processed through the
structure at that point was still
unclear to me
I think everyone assumed that people
were captured in the course of
hostilities in Afghanistan perhaps the
individuals who were suspected of being
responsible for the attacks on 9/11
would be you know candidates to me for
trial by military commission it did
strike me as odd that sort of an
exceptional structure was created thus
in the same way I guess that that I
was having a hard time accepting the the
war paradigm I mean I remember well I
think yeah you know the the notion that
the 9/11 attacks were an act of war I
think was a notion that was very quickly
put out there by you know within
political spheres I think it was the
immediate reaction of folks within the
Department of Defense of course they're
conditioned to interpret events in that
way because of their own training and
professional background as military
people but I think very quickly even
within civilians fears of our political
leadership that view was adopted it was
publicized through the media and it was
very quickly accepted by journalists
commentators analysts and the public
that that notion was so quickly accepted
was was troubling to me because I
thought I thought it deserved more
reflection and debate because it's
really it is really a significant shift
and I think had had the attacks on 9/11
been treated as you know perhaps a
particularly tragic and horrendously
successful criminal action then the
course of history would have would have
been very different the fact that very
early on they were just you know
relatively unquestioningly accepted as
an act of war and that the war paradigm
was it was a really question to
interrogate it significantly by you know
the elected representation being on the
hill or by or by the intelligentsia and
the academy and commentators and
analysts and reporters I think that set
us on a path that we're still on today
so so very early on for the same reason
that I that I had some doubts about the
wisdom or propriety of the war framing
for for this particular historical event
as tragic as it was and as personally
affected as I was by it as a New Yorker
I still questioned that and I think the
the order announcing the creation of the
military commissions and my reaction to
it was sort of part of that same bundle
and I also wondered I mean even if we
were to accept the war framing for what
was happening at the time I also
wondered why we had to create a new
military judicial structure when we
already had the courts martial in
addition of course to our you know
civilian article 3 federal courts so
that was my initial reaction I think my
my next really meaningful engagement
with the military commissions comes
years later when I think it was in and
on August 8 2008 actually it was one
when I was retained by ahmed al darby
who was a prisoner at guantanamo i talk
about how that happened so he had you
know shortly before my first meeting
with him on august 8th 2008 he had been
referred charged and referred for trial
by military commission at this point
we're talking about the legislative
version the post Hamadan version of the
military commission so you could think
of it as version 2.0 3.0 depending on
how you you don't want to look at the
evolution over time he he had been
appointed detailed military defense
counsel as you know consistent with the
military commissions act and the
implementing rules that the Department
of Defense issued he wanted to retain
civilian counsel to represent him before
the military commissions one of the men
who was imprisoned in the same prison
camp where he was held which at the time
was Camp four which is no longer in use
it's a facility that's a part of Camp
Delta avantime mill no longer in use
today as far as I know at least I want
animal but it was account for was where
so-called compliant prisoners were held
back in 2008 so the prisoners were given
you know white jumpsuits and they had
privileges that the prisoners in camps
five and six and the other prison camps
at the time the
so a little Darby was held in that camp
one of his fellow prisoners there was a
client of mine
an Algerian man by the name of Mohammed
Ahmed who is now back home with his
family in Algeria and through Mohammed I
received a request from mr. elder Bai
madam Darby to to represent him so you
know we exchanged I exchanged
correspondence like legal mail with mr.
on debt abhi and then on August 8 2008 I
had my first meeting with him and began
sort of solidifying the attorney-client
relationship with him that still exists
till today so that was really my first
meaningful engagement with the military
commissions as a lawyer shortly after
that meeting I entered my appearance as
his you know civilian defense lawyer
before the Commission's under the
military commission rules and under the
normal sort of courts martial rules as
well whenever there is a civilian lawyer
on a case before a court-martial or
before a military commission that
civilian water becomes lead counsel even
if there is a military lorry so you know
I collaborated with his military lawyer
at the time since that time he's had you
know about six different military
lawyers and I've been well you know the
one civilian defense lawyer on the case
for the for the duration what happened
the case actually is interesting because
it really I think it really reflects a
lot of what's wrong with the military
commissions and so so you know he was
charged he was referred and charged he
was charged and referred in 2008 you
know we started moving towards trial we
eventually reached the suppression phase
so one of the final pre-trial phases in
any like you know criminal proceeding
and he had been charged with the what
was what was back then the normal sort
of military commission cocktail of
charges material support conspiracy both
of which are not recognized offenses
under the law of war and that's one of
the arguments we made at this point in
time 2013 the DC Circuit Court of
Appeals has agreed with us as to
material support
there are more or less on the brink of
agreeing with us as to conspiracy I
think even the office of the chief
prosecutor as a legal matter has
probably agrees with us as illegal as a
legal matter that conspiracy is not a
war crime that's recognized under
international law but I think as a
matter of policy that office is no
longer interested in charging that
particular crime because they're afraid
of you know how convictions of that
crime could stand on on on appeal but at
the time in 2008 mr. Darby was charged
with no support conspiracy we were on
our way to trial we were at the
suppression phase where we were
basically making all kinds of arguments
about what sorts of evidence the
government should be able to rely upon
and which sets of evidence were too
prejudicial and whatnot
so just to give you an example I mean
obviously we were arguing over the
miscibility of some of his own
statements that they were going to try
to introduce against him given the
circumstances in which he had been
interrogated in Bagram and Guantanamo
highly coercive circumstances mr. Darvey
even you know signed a declaration
describing the torture and abuse that he
survived in Bagram of Guantanamo that
declaration is now public and absolutely
tragic
yeah I mean it's and it's and you know
his is one of the more extreme cases out
of out of Bagram that we know about at
least but but obviously there are two
prisoners that we know of who died
including Dilawar whose death he more or
less witnessed so so I think you know
there was a lot of really powerful
moving you know details and his accounts
of you know how certain statements were
elicited from him the the other part of
it obviously was also having to do with
evidence that the government wanted to
introduce about the 9/11 attacks so a
lot of what we were saying from the
defense side was you know this is
prejudicial because even going by the
government's own allegations
you know mr. Darvey didn't have anything
to do with the 9/11 attacks and so why
introduce that and you know tainting the
military commission members like the
military jurors view of our client so
you know we won some we lost some in
front of Chief Judge pol who
you know was our judge in the alder B
case is the judge now in the 911 trial
in the Hanafi trial the only ongoing
sort of proceedings before the military
commissions at Guantanamo today in 2013
so back in 2008 he issued some rulings
that were favorable to us some rulings
that were not favorable to us I guess
you know part of the calculus on the
government side was that there was a new
administration coming in
moreover they didn't particularly like
some of judge pols rulings on
suppression and because it's the
commissions because under the Commission
rules there is no speedy trial clock
because they can hit the reset button as
many times as they want to obviously
they took advantage of that and so they
basically pulled the plug on their own
case they withdrew the charges they had
them dismissed bringing mr. Alzado be
back to where he was before he had been
ever charged with anything so in a in a
normal judicial proceeding that would be
considered a huge success for the
defense right you managed to get the
charges against your client dropped but
in the military commissions it's sort of
meaningless I mean I'm not I'm not
trying to minimize the reality that it
was a relief to mr. Buchanan no longer
be in sort of an jeopardy in that way
and legal jeopardy in that way but but
it was meaningless in the sense that
they could renew the charges the very
next day or two or three years later
which is what they did right so you know
the charges are withdrawn and dismissed
by the prosecution in 2009 Obama
administration comes in they choose to
you know hold on to at that point you
know it became clear that they've chosen
to hold on to the military commissions
which you know they should have scrapped
for a bunch of reasons including the
ones I've mentioned and many others that
we'll get to and and essentially you
know we were in a holding pattern in
that case on the Commission's side until
August of 2012 when new charges were
sworn and now those charges have still
not been referred so the Military
Commission system like any like the
courts-martial system functions in a way
where the military prosecutors
a set of charges those charges go to
what's called a convening authority and
only when the convening authority signs
off on the charges and refers them to a
military commission does the case move
forward but again because it's the
Commission's in kangaroo like fashion
for lack of a better time you know that
that can take forever and so for over a
year at this point the sworn charges the
new set of sworn charges from August
2012 against a vendetta be remain
pending before the convening authority
awaiting action so when my client asks
me whether or when this case is ever
going to move forward I can't answer
that because it's in the convening
authority hands and there is no there's
no structural pressure on him to take
action he can sit on it forever he could
move on it tomorrow
what's it was one thing that was
interesting to note and this also
illustrates sort of how the Military
Commission system by design it was set
up to favor the prosecution even more
shows yeah even more so than any other I
mean I don't I'm very critical of the
way that the articles we like the
federal courts function and even the way
state courts function in criminal cases
but you know even if you look at just
how federal courts function and you know
so-called terrorism trials it's hugely
problematic and we can have a completely
separate conversation about that but the
military commissions stack the odds in
the prosecution's favor even even higher
I mean the it's a it's a system that is
that was designed to produce convictions
over justice it is designed to offer
prosecutors all sorts of shortcuts it is
designed to protect the secrecy that the
government wants to protect so secret
evidence can be used coerced evidence
can be used the accused can be excluded
from their own proceedings in many ways
sometimes you know it's argue I think
the prosecutors might argue sometimes
that they can proceed ex parte excluding
even defense lawyers so it's really it's
really a system that offers the
prosecution
all sorts of shortcuts the most
important I think function of the
military commissions and this is where
the secrecy comes in is is to enable the
government to proceed with these cases
despite the elephant in the room which
is torture
because all of these cases have torture
at their heart mr. Alda are being
included mr. all dog be being an example
obviously the nine eleven five being
another example of people like Herman
I'm not sure as well I mean any any case
that you can think of that's being
talked about in the context of military
commissions today will you know will by
necessity feature torture prominently
and that's and that kind of explains the
design of the military commissions
because if he there would be no need for
their existence were not for that
imperative getting around torture being
able to secure convictions
despite the sort of the prominent role
that torture played in a lot of you know
the histories of these cases so you know
with mr. alder be the the charges that
you know were sworn out in August 2012
remain pending and and you know we're
just basically in a holding pattern but
the other thing you mentioned before
testimony gotten through coercion is
allowed but testimony gotten through
torture is not allowed yeah I mean but
even that right I mean it's like so what
is love look at it in three ways right I
mean there are there are three
conceivable grades legally you can think
of torture as sort of the highest most
extreme form of sort of coercion you can
think sort of the next lowest thing
would be cruel inhuman and degrading
treatment and then below that is
coercion statements extracted through
any of the three coercion CID T or
torture would be considered involuntary
now the the Commission rules as they
exist today are clear that tortured
evidence perhaps even CID T evidence
cruel inhuman and degrading treatment
evidence
is not admissible but who makes that
determination the military judge so if a
military judge presiding over a military
commission of Guantanamo decides that
despite the defense's argument that
particular forms of coercion constituted
torture the military judge and his or
her discretion deems that the abuse that
took place does not rise legally to the
level of torture then he can simply make
the decision about whether it's you know
if it's probative enough in his view it
can be admitted it can be used and so
that's even even where the military
commissions pay lip service to the
notion that tortured evidence cannot be
introduced at trial against the
defendant the devil is always in the
details with the military commissions
and when you look at the practice of it
it vests the military judge with a great
deal of discretion and that's
complicated I mean I think what would
would have further highlights how
troubling that is is when you look at
the military commission rules there are
provisions that insulate the military
commissions both ways in the sense that
if a military committee if a judge a
military judge in a military commission
issues a ruling on the legal question
that opinion that was written by the
military judge if he wrote an opinion
cannot be used in the regular courts
martial system there's a provision and
the rules that prevents sort of anyone
from citing what a military judge the
military commission says as precedent in
the regular military courts why is that
because we want to insulate our own men
and women in uniform from the bad law
that the military commissions are going
to create and that goes both ways right
and so I can I can spend all day citing
Supreme Court precedent precedent from
the highest military court international
law to a military judge in my military
Commission case but ultimately it is
entirely up to her or him to decide
whether or not to follow that law none
of that law is binding on on her or him
now probably in practice because the
judges are going to be lawyers just by
reflex by professional reflex they're
going to tend towards deference to those
authorities
they know that they aren't bound by
those authorities and and sometimes
where it really matters they will say
well you know this is not a regular
court these are not regular cases you
know the authority you cite is
instructive but you know it isn't
binding and here are the reasons why I'm
going to go a different way instructive
this you know it seems like this
Orwellian use of language almost
especially when you're talking about
coercive techniques or interrogations or
torture it's what what we say is okay
and you can just stick with that legal
precedent that's that's how you have to
that's how you're forced to go forward
yeah I mean the use of language I mean
you can you can look at it from the
Commission's on down to you know even
the everyday conditions that our clients
at Guantanamo my clients that go on
tottemo endure and how they're described
by the authorities so if I if I go to
the media and say you know my client
shakir honor has been held in solitary
for months and then the media takes that
like a journalist takes that back to the
Department of Defense at Guantanamo and
says you know Jacques Rama's lawyer is
saying that you know he's in solitary
what they'll say in response is no way
we don't have solitary confinement at
Guantanamo and the reason for that again
is they've they've defined it so
narrowly as to define them out of
existence so in their view it cannot be
solitary based on their definition as
long as the prisoner can hear another
prisoners voice so even if Shaq are
armored and this is this is true I mean
this has happened with not just with
chalk or with many of my clients but
even if you know taking shocker as an
example
Shakur spends 23 hours out of every day
on lockdown by himself in his steel cell
8 feet by 5 he is allowed out to a
recreation cage from 2:00 to 4:00 a.m.
by himself has no social contact with
anyone other than his guards as long as
Shakur american-like been down in his
cell shout through the slot in his metal
door through which they give him food to
another prisoner who may be at the other
end of the
cell block in his cell and as long as
that prisoner can hear shocker
shouted and can respond and shocker
might be able to hear him in the
military's view for that reason it is
not solved here even though he has no
real actual human contact exact with
exactly and by every recognized legal
definition including the one we use in
domestic prison facilities that is
Salter most most domestic prisoners
wouldn't even argue with that federal or
state run hmm they would concede yes
that's solitary confinement it's and and
it's even it's even gotten so ridiculous
that I you know shocker the same client
once described to me that you know he
would tell he would tell his captors
that you know because he speaks fluent
English and so his complaint to them
about being held in isolation which is a
synonym for solitary confinement heard
and they would dispute that and then he
told me that he was being taken to a
meeting with me and on his way to the
meeting on his way out of his cell block
there was some kind of an LCD display I
guess regulating I don't know if it's
like electric flow or the air
conditioning flow into the cell block
there was a there was an LCD display
that basically read isolation block and
so so he was laughing because he was
saying you know their own their own
systems acknowledge that that this is an
isolation block yet they refused to
acknowledge that in conversation with
him and maybe we can get to a little bit
more about shocker elmer a little later
but i wonder if we can go back to to
ahmed all darby for a little bit and
talk about how he ended up in guantanamo
in the first place and what his story
was there yeah i mean i think a lot of
that is actually in his
or some of that isn't his declaration
it's probably best for me not to like
get into it too much okay so fine yeah
absolutely
so going back to but in terms of like
well we were taught we started with the
Commission's you feel like we've sort of
covered that enough for we can keep
going on the Commission's if you want to
it's up to you I mean if you have other
you know questions about the
Commission's or if you'd rather move on
completed defer to you well you talked
about how he is he's basically just just
languishing now he's waiting for the
convening authority to do something with
the charges that are before him you know
so he's basically in a in a state of
legal limbo and has been for a while
yeah right so so what's next for for him
yeah I think I think that there really
isn't much I can say this is exactly the
question he'll ask him you know it's
really it's really sort of out of our
control
and in a normal court system we would
have been able to say look there's uh
there's a speedy trial clock that has
won and so now we can go to a court and
ask for you to be released they're not
gonna charge you but that's simply not
the way it works here because the
government can have it both ways again
going back to sort of that earliest
moment that earliest sort of bifurcation
in the world when we went down the warp
sort of paradigm path I think given that
that's where we are now the government
can always fall back on continued
indefinite imprisonment under their
interpretation of the law of war making
the men in Guantanamo in their view in
the government's view detain a Boleyn
told the end of hostilities that have
you know they're very hard to define
right because they're not geographically
or temporally limited I'm sure there are
some actors in government who would say
you know even after the end of
hostilities in Afghanistan
the conflict still won't be over and so
so it's really unclear but again within
that war paradigm the government has a
host of options and I think that's
what's really dangerous the ability of
the the ability of the government to
toggle between these different modes of
state violence so the fact that the
government has a range of options at its
disposal you know that that are
reflected in what we now know is the
government calls the disposition matrix
right that they can for any particular
individual that is of interest to the
government as long as certain parameters
are met right that they be overseas for
example there's a range of options you
can try that person you can execute that
person you can you know send them over
to another country for questioning and
detention you can hold them indefinitely
in a US military facility you can bring
them to the United States and make them
stand trial before a federal court you
can hold them in a military facility and
try them by military commission or not
or hold them indefinitely under the law
of war as long as you know they qualify
as an unprivileged enemy belligerent
which is sort of the success return to
enemy come back so the fact that the
government has all of these options at
its disposal is what's really troubling
and I think that's that's different from
the way things stood I think before this
historical moment like this post 9/11
moment not that the government didn't
engage in all kinds of dirty business
back then but I think the default the
norm back then was that publicly
whatever dirty work the government was
engaged in wasn't acknowledged and
claimed as a legitimate policy option
the way it is today today a lot of this
stuff is on the table a lot of stuff
that previously may have been done
covertly you know whether we know about
it or not
today is sort of openly a part of the
legitimate array of options at the
government's disposal or sort of that
array of options that the government
claimed
is legitimate and they keep changing the
rules and extending this stays of
imprisonment and yeah so we were so we'd
said we talked about Commission's and
then do a couple other things on your
list too right yeah we could move on to
talking a bit about the hunger strike of
this past year okay so your client mr.
Zuhair had been on his own hunger strike
for a very long period of time before he
was ultimately released in your your
client currently mr. Faraj participated
in the one that I guess the numbers grew
to about 100 or even possibly more what
was your what was your reaction to to
this year's massive sort of hunger
strike compared to the one that you saw
your client mr. Zuhair go through yeah
so I went ahead
you know Saudi national Haldor
Guantanamo he launched his own
individual hunger strike in June of 2005
and and you know wasn't I mean there was
a group of people who were with him but
you know most of them sort of came in
and out of hunger striking over a period
of years but mr. Zhu here and another
Saudi national by the name of Shalaby
who began his hunger strike a couple of
weeks after Ahmed did in June of 2005
they stayed they sort of there were
continuous hunger strike because they
never they never suspended their hunger
strike mr. Shelby remains on hunger
strike today so when you think of it
this is a man who has been
uninterrupted hunger strike since June
of 2005 he's the you know single single
longest-running hunger striker at
Guantanamo I'm sure he shattered all
kinds of World Records and he's paid the
price I think with his health both
physical and I'm sure to an extent you
know psychological and emotional mr. zoo
head basically you know he started his
hunger hunger strike in 2005 when I
first met with him in 2006 when he
retained me and and and and my team of
students to represent him and at the
time I was teaching at I was about to
start teaching at Yale Law School and I
was there from 2007 to 2009 and
represented him with the team of
students there out of Yale Law School he
one of the first things he said to me
was you know I'm you know here's how
we're going to work you know I requested
use my attorney and I'm going to come
for all of our meetings I'm going to be
you know frank and truthful with you
whatever whatever I can provide you with
- you know facilitate your work I'll do
that but in exchange you know I don't
want you to ever try to talk me out of
my hunger strike and and he made it very
clear to me and to my students from the
earliest point that you know this was
the one way that he had left to you know
exercise his his human dignity and his
autonomy in his agency it was a peaceful
form of protest and resistance and
justice that he really wanted to engage
in and he made it very clear to us that
he would not you know and his hunger
strike before before being returned to
his homeland of Saudi Arabia and you
know that's exactly what he did he you
know we we represented him we you know
we began representing him in 2006 2007
boumedienne came down so we
we pressed forward as a girl as
aggressively as we could we had a good
judge on the case who sort of you know
was equally mindful like a fair judge
was equally mindful of our clients own
interests and how significant the
deprivation of his Liberty had been
alongside
you know the equities on the government
side you know national security equities
were not so we had a fair judge we
pressed forward aggressively we after
blue India and we have the government
produced their factual return which is
their evidentiary justification for mr.
Harris imprisonment part of that was
classified part of it was unclassified
we responded to we filed a traverse
which is a response to the government's
accusations and whatever evidence they
put forth a third of what we said was
public on the unclassified side
two-thirds were on the classified side
were working with the government towards
declassifying that but just to summarize
it without getting into anything you
know sensitive you know the accusations
were very very poorly and thinly
substantiated we were literally able to
rip apart the evidence that the
government presented and once we saw
that we we started pressing for a trial
because we had responded in writing with
our own evidence and with our own
rebuttals of the government's evidence
and we really wanted to go to trial to
get our judge to look at everything we
had put forth and make a decision
whether or not mr. Harris imprisonment
for all these years have been justified
legal the government resisted that to an
extent they they didn't want the judge
to set a trial date but ultimately the
judge did he set a trial date towards
the end of June 2009 if I remember
correctly on June 12th 2009
exactly the first anniversary of the
boumedienne Supreme Court decision
holding that the prisoners at Guantanamo
had a right to habeas corpus review my
students and I got a communication from
the US Department of Justice informing
us that mr. haire had been placed on a
plane to be returned to Saudi Arabia
that was their way I think of avoiding
the embarrassment of going to trial and
losing because I think you know with the
with the evidence we had put forth the
way we had responded to their evidence
and the fact that we had a judge who was
not afraid of you know contradicting the
government on matters of so-called
national security they kind of saw the
writing on the wall and decided that you
know the path of least resistance would
be to send them back to Saudi Arabia so
he actually you know kept his promise I
mean he he remained on hunger strike all
the way hand till his foot hit Saudi
soil and only then did he interrupted
hunger strike when he saw his mother he
was placed in the Saudi rehabilitation
reintegration program and now that's a
form of detention and in my view I mean
obviously it's not it is in Guantanamo
and obviously it isn't like sort of your
average Saudi prison either in the sense
that it's better but but it's still a
deprivation of Liberty so for three
years past that point he remained in the
Saudi rehabilitation reintegration
program until the spring of 2012 when he
was finally released for good and so now
you know he's home with his family in
Mecca Saudi Arabia he recently agreed to
give The Associated Press an interview
about his experiences commenting on I
mean I think the journalists from The
Associated Press his interest was really
to get some insight into the mentality
of a Honolulu strike where the
motivations of a hunger strike or what
it's like to be in that position at
Guantanamo and so I met obviously is
uniquely positioned to shed light on
that and you know he's the next best
thing to being able to interview an
actual hunger striker at all time and so
he agreed to do that interview and you
know he explained to the journalists
that it was sort of the one way of you
know protesting peacefully like the
injustice of lanthanum Oh
and and that you know many times you
know that often his family his own
family wouldn't didn't understand and
couldn't understand that the prisoners
families just couldn't understand what
it's like to be there and why you know
their loved ones feel compelled to
engage and something as Extreme as
hunger-striking
extreme in the sense that it really
really exact a cost physically and
psychologically and sometimes it's a
long-term cost I mean part of what mr.
Zhu here explained to the Associated
Press journalists is that even today in
2013 years after he finally suspended
his hunger strike he still suffers from
some of the physical health consequences
of having been on hunger strike for such
a long period of time that his back just
hasn't been the same that his joints
just don't feel the same he used to be
extremely athletic he just isn't able to
do any of that anymore and he's still a
relatively young man so so I think I
think but but for him you know I think
it was the way it was the way he chose
to you know remain human at Guantanamo
and as paradoxical as it might sound I
think for him it was it was the way
perhaps the only way to survive one time
hmm to sort of put himself at great risk
not just because of the effects of
hunger striking on his own system
physically and mentally but also because
of the authorities response to a hunger
striking and their constant attempts at
breaking as well and we saw a lot of
that play out with the recent hunger
strike at Guantanamo so you know Mike as
you mentioned my client Abdul Ahad a
fella who's a Syrian national my other
client mahathat Hadley who's a Yemeni
national both of them actually all of my
clients went on hunger strike shock
Adama was also on hunger strike mohammed
al thani in saudi was on hunger strike
for a short period of time he was also
on hunger strike but and as you
mentioned you know had its height that
hunger strike included the majority of
the prisoners at Guantanamo depending on
whose count you believe you know the
prisoners will say up to 140 the
president authorities were saying you
know
different figures between 100 and 120
out of the 166 prisoners that were there
at the time but essentially the majority
of the prison population in Guantanamo
had launched a concerted collective
hunger strike and you know the the spark
for it obviously was a particular
incident where prisoners believed that
prison authorities had searched the the
qur'an's in a way that they hadn't
before so I think that was the spark but
the real underlying motivation that
fueled the hunger strike as expressed by
my clients and other prisoners was just
the the single constant unchanging
characteristic of Guantanamo that has
remained the same whether you look at
Guantanamo in 2002 or you look at it in
2013 regardless of changes and
conditions which is the reality of
indefinite imprisonment without charged
without knowing whether or not you will
ever you know get to be reunited with
your family with your society with your
loved ones and many legal and medical
experts will tell you that something as
extreme is that indefinite imprisonment
without sort of knowing without any kind
of certainty about if you'll ever get
out that that can amount to
psychological torture so even if you set
aside all the horrible things that we've
we know some of the men at Guantanamo
have survived
we know from government documents now we
know from survivor accounts we know from
their own stories even if you set all
that aside just that one constant
unchanging fact that you know they're
being held they don't know if they're
ever going to get out that's really hard
to negotiate and and I would say not
just for the prisoners themselves but
also for their for their spouses for
their loved ones for their families so
it has a the effect sort of ripples out
and and touches not only the prisoners
and their immediate families but also
their societies and their communities as
a whole
particularly you know if you sort of
take into account the way societies like
Yemen are structured and the importance
of expanded families and clan and tribal
relations so the so really like that
ripple that rippling out of individuals
who were affected by by this injustice
that's being visited on the man of
Guantanamo really brings in many many
more people than the most I think
America has realized so you know with
this hunger strike I mean what was
notable to me was that they were able to
was that it was there was sort of a
unity in motivation and an action mm-hmm
that prisoners who have very different
outlooks who have very different
political perspectives who have very
different individual goals and desires
were able to find really in action and
motivation to that extent that the
overwhelming majority of the prisoners
would engage in sort of a single act of
political protest and it was and it was
it was successful I mean in the sense
that politically they were able to
leverage that action and transform it
into political pressure that led that
brought President Obama from a place
where he was not willing to even talk
about Guantanamo to a place where he was
forced to address it twice and to public
addresses to a place where he was forced
to revoke the moratorium on
repatriations to Yemen and Saudi Arabia
to a place where he reopened the office
of Guantanamo closure appointed in every
way and I don't want to overstate the
importance of all of that because we had
an EM void for the closure of Guantanamo
for years from 2009 the entire first
term of the Obama presidency until until
Obama shut down that office and little
was done so ultimately what it boils
down to is political will President
Obama's willingness to make good on that
promise it's really like you know pay
the political price and expend the
political capital to make good on the
promise of closing that particular
facility and that that will that
political will on the
administration's part has been lacking
for the better part of that first
presidential term we hope that what's
happening now is a change and that you
know the two Algerians who were recently
released in 2013 and sent back home will
be you know the first of many it makes
sense to start with the prisoners you
know the majority of prisoners at
Guantanamo have already been approved
for release but I don't really I don't
really buy into that distinction too
much i I think I think essentially all
the prisoners of want animal should be
either released or charged ultimately
and that there is no place for it you
know indefinite law of war detention in
this kind of context so so to my mind
you know if the administration wants to
start with those who've been cleared for
release of that makes sense for
bureaucratic reasons so be it but but
but all of the prisoners must be
repatriated or released or or charged
and tried if there's a basis for it but
I think that the hunger strike was was
was successful politically bringing all
these different kinds of pressure to
bear on the American political
administration via international
pressures from allies from international
organizations from human rights groups
who were denouncing the hunger strike
denouncing you know indefinite
imprisonment a renewed international
media attention on Guantanamo and the
injustice of indefinite imprisonment I
mean so much so that you know segments
of the American public were taking
notice
rolling hunger strikes were organized
nationwide solidarity hunger strikes
among Americans and these these
expressions of solidarity I think were
among the most meaningful for my clients
at Guantanamo at least you know when I
would describe to them the actions by
organizations like witness against
torture the the ruling solidarity hunger
strikes the fact that people were like
staging protests outside of the White
House and you know people on hunger
strike Americans I think that really
resonated with that I mean they're very
grateful and they're very thankful for
any gesture of solidarity but but they
they were always very I mean across
clients they were always very
intentional about asking me to you know
conveyed their thanks and their
appreciation to those members of the
American public who stood by their side
in their time of need and I think sort
of the building of those kinds of
bridges and alliances is really
transformative I trust
for the people here in the US who take
those actions and it's transformative
for my clients who you know brings them
to a different understanding of the
complexity of American society and so I
you know say I do think that that act of
collective protest was tremendously
successful it's not unusual I mean there
are there studies that will tell you
that prison hunger strikes are
successful to the order of 70 percent so
so the odds you know once a once a
prisoner is willing to sort of pay that
price and take the extraordinary step of
endangering their own life and going on
hunger strike they will be able to
achieve some political - as but perhaps
not all of their goals but at least some
of them and I think for most of the
prisoners at Guantanamo today who were
on hunger strike they're not waiting to
see like many of them have chosen to
give the Obama administration a reprieve
they've suspended their hunger strike
temporarily now that the Algerians have
been released to see if more releases
will follow if if if they come to a
point where they realize that you know
the the release of the Algerians was
just sort of a blip an aberration and
and really the policy hasn't changed the
political will as still as it was before
the inertia is still the same then I
think they'll go back to their hunger
strike if on the other hand they see
sort of what a favorable evolution over
time with more prisoners released then I
think they'll they'll go on eating
another those however I think at this
point 30 to 40 prisoners were still
being force-fed tube-fed including you
know my clients
Mazal hungry and hundun how to furnish
at least on my information from my last
contact with them so they're they're
maintaining their hunger strike because
they're you know there's somewhat more
skeptical but I think many other
prisoners have decided to sort of
suspend it at least temporarily to see
what the administration does see how it
goes
the
the hunger strike really brought the
human cost of Guantanamo back in to the
public eye yep
and that is something that is so often
glossed over with all this talk about
politics and what the Obama
administration should be doing versus
what it the first is what it actually is
doing can you talk a little bit about
the the human cost as you saw it and
your experience with your clients yeah I
mean look it's it's primarily I mean I
think for many pundits and many lawyers
and many people who track this stuff
here in the United States it's almost
like a soap opera having to do with you
know judicial opinions and what if the
courts said here and what if the policy
makers saying there I mean to me that's
to me that's part of the problem in the
sense then in a way unwittingly it
participates in a process of
dehumanization because it takes the
humanity of the population that is most
directly affected out of the picture all
together and kind of like elevates the
sort of this this human situation to
really just a policy and legal debate so
for me primarily it's about the people
involved and for my students the same is
true I mean I think that's really the
main motivation for my students who are
working on these cases and the people
involved include our clients obviously
who were sort of most immediately in the
crosshairs but also their families their
communities their societies and we try
to work with all of those circles so so
I mean I you know there's no mean you
know for for shocker Amador he he hasn't
you know he never met his son for
example you know he has a son who was
born on February 14th
2002 which is one which was when chakram
arrived at Guantanamo having been held
at Kandahar before in US custody idol
Darby same thing he's got a son whom you
know is what his wife was pregnant with
that child when he was taken into US
custody he's never met that child he's
also lost his father while he was in
prison but Zuhair lost apparently when
he was in prison
Mars was it Halloween you know has lost
you know relatives I've done a
difference doesn't even know if his
family is still alive in Syria hmm
because of what's going on there these
are you know real lasting human costs I
mean they're their tragedies really and
and sometimes it's surprise to me that
you know my clients have been able to
survive to the extent that they have not
just physically but also like
psychologically and emotionally this
bite sort of the difficulty of all that
it's kind of unfathomable really that
that you know they can they can keep it
together despite all that when I think
about my client I mean I Becky who you
know was kidnapped off the streets of
Thailand probably by the CIA in 2002 has
been in US custody since then now Bagram
you know I mean the same thing he hasn't
seen his children his father who's been
advocating relentlessly on his behalf
you know finds it really hard to process
hardened years I mean he's told me he's
like he's told me you know if it don't
if you have bad news
don't call me call my son it means
brother so whenever there's like bad
news or negative developments in the
case or in the advocacy efforts that
were undertaking on behalf of I mean or
other Bagram prisoners all call and
means brother if there's good news I'll
call his dad I mean his dad is an older
man he's you know he just can't he just
can't bear it and and I think that's
true for many people like my mother on
their mouthes Irian client you know when
I when I picked up the phone of my
students to call his wife to let her
know that he was on a plane to Algeria
she broke down and she like there was
silence and then she broke down in tears
and cried and that was the first time I
had heard her cry
and we'd been working with her for years
we've been getting documents from her
she had been sort of a very steadfast
advocate on her husband's behalf and she
was a huge support to our efforts
legally and you know just it occurred to
me that in there then just despite all
of our work with her all those years
leading up to his release she never once
allowed herself to cry it was only once
we told her that he was finally on a
plane headed home that she was able to
like let her guard down I guess and so
that really triggered something for me
like I mean I I mean I realized this
sort of at an abstract level but it
really made it very concrete for me when
when that happened on the phone and she
started crying you know just how just
how difficult and impossible you know
this is not just for the prisoners
themselves but you know for their
families and larger circles so yeah I
mean obviously we can talk about the
policy ramifications as well the fact
that the fact that the Obama
administration you know even if it gets
to a point where it closes the prisoner
Guantanamo that that at that point in
time the closure of that particular
facility is going to be largely symbolic
because the policy of indefinite
military imprisonment without charge
like that policy option will have been
fully preserved by the Obama
administration and what better
illustration of that what better proof
of what I just said then the existence
of the president of Bagram where I mean
el bakry is being held right because
because over there the Obama
administration actually you know and
we're gonna be we're going to court
before the coup going before the court
of appeals on Tuesday for the second
time on the jurisdictional question of
Bagram so the Obama administration it
continues to argue along the exact same
lines that the Bush administration
argued with respect to Guantanamo back
in 2003 and 2004 before Rasool which is
to say that with respect to Bagram the
Obama administration continues to say
today in 2013 and they will say this in
court before the DC Circuit Court of
Appeals on Tuesday that the jurisdiction
of US federal courts does not extend to
what the US government does to men
imprisoned at Bagram in Afghanistan
because it's a theater of war and
irrespective of the fact that those men
were brought into that theater of war
man like Amina Buckley were brought into
that theater of war by the United States
so they will continue to make that
argument that's the exact it's very
similar to the argument that the Bush
administration made as to Guantanamo
saying hey no jurisdiction of Guantanamo
so when you think about that I think it
really highlights the fact that the
Obama administration wants to preserve
that option wants to preserve the option
of being able to hold people
indefinitely without charge even if it
brought those people into a theater of
hostilities man and that's a really
radical notion that that that a
government can kidnap someone from
someone who is not a citizen of a
country at war with the United States
can kidnap them off the streets of
another country that is not at war with
the United States that is far from any
recognizable battlefield that they can
take them into a battlefield into a
detention facility that is within a
battlefield like Afghanistan a zone of
hostilities which button love itself is
a violation of all kinds of
international law right the fact of an
abduction rendition let alone rendition
into a zone of hostilities which is
dangerous right in Afghanistan 2002 2003
that the US government could kidnap that
sort of person from a place like
Thailand bring them into a theater of
hostilities like Afghanistan and then go
into federal court and say judge you
have no authority to review the legality
of this person's detention because they
are in their zone of hostilities even
though we brought them there by our own
discretion hmm that's a clear roadmap
that allows this administration any
future US administration to circumvent
any meaningful judicial review over the
imprisonment of people overseas and
that's that's the policy option that's
the option that's the tool that the
Obama administration is fighting so hard
in federal court to preserve we are just
trying to get into the door we're trying
to get you know mr. Albuquerque his day
in court essentially we just want to be
able to
before an impartial judge and say judge
here are the government's accusations
here's what they claim as the evidence
that justifies his imprisonment for well
over a decade at this point without
charge here's our answer you decide
whether or not this man's imprisonment
is legal that's all we want to do but
we're still at the threshold we're still
trying to get through the door and the
Obama administration is taking a
position that is virtually
indistinguishable from the position that
the Bush administration took over a
decade ago with respect to Guantanamo
and so I think that that's just one
illustration of kind of the longitudinal
and you know impact of the Obama
administration's normalization of many
Bush era policies because now that the
Obama administration has fought so hard
to preserve this kind of option
indefinite imprisonment have place like
Bagram for non-citizens
you know I think it's a challenge that
will be with us for a generation or more
along with a bunch of other you know
policies it's a very dangerous precedent
to set yeah absolutely and Bagram so
rarely gets mentioned when we're talking
about one time oh but in in fact it's a
much larger much worse facility one of
the one of the things I saw this week
was and this goes back to our
conversation about the human cost in
humanizing the individuals detained at
Guantanamo it was this piece in the in
the Miami Herald of it was a feature of
photographs of the detainees I saw it
yeah and that's such a such a rarity the
in terms of battlefield photography any
photography that comes out of Guantanamo
just pictures of the of the detainees
besides what looked like just mug shots
it seems like there that is that in and
of itself is an effort to keep this
keep this issue as out of the hearts and
minds of the American people as possible
to completely dehumanize them and as you
say your client Shaka Rama hasn't hasn't
seen his own child
Shaka Rama is one one detainee who it
seems there are much more campaigns to
to get his release than most of the
others can you talk a little bit about
about what his what his status is and
some of those campaigns I guess
especially in the UK that of that have
occurred to try to get his release yeah
I mean I think you know he I mean chakra
doesn't view himself as in any way like
different or you know from other
prisoners on Guantanamo and I think he
views his own individual struggle as a
part of that collective struggle and he
said many times that really is his
objective isn't you know his objective
isn't so much his own release as it is
like the the shuttering of that prison
as a whole and that if if by accepting
release himself he can be in a position
to accelerate the shuttering of the
prison for example you know he's
returned to his family in the United
Kingdom and he's able to speak out and
if that accelerates the process of
closing the president so be it but he's
always linked his own individual
struggle his own personal struggle to
the larger political one the larger sort
of group struggle that involves all the
prisoners at Guantanamo I think you know
Shaq has been he doesn't view himself as
you know different or exceptional but I
think the outside world you know I mean
you've you've kind of you know you've
touched on this that there are these
campaigns that have to do with checkers
release and you don't see similar
campaigns for others and I think part of
it is because you know he's a former UK
resident he has family in the United
Kingdom they're all UK subjects that
they that they speak English that they
come from english-speaking market that
they're advocates I mean it's I think
there's a sort of a collection of
factors that kind of make his case more
Padel palatable to you know
english-speaking audiences in the UK or
the United States substantively it
really isn't different I mean it's
indefinite imprisonment there are many
other prisoners like him at Guantanamo
including ones who have been approved
for release by the Obama in the bush
administrations right so he doesn't view
himself as different the Western public
or some segments of the Western public
might for reasons having to do with his
I guess immigration status that he was a
former UK resident that has you know
spouse and kids are all UK nationals
I think the the prison administration
may view him as different but again that
is not for reasons having to do with
what he did before Guantanamo or what
he's alleged to them before Guantanamo
however it is entirely for reasons
having to do with what he's seen as
having engaged in since his arrival at
Guantanamo some of which he proudly owns
like the fact that he has no interest in
being seen as a compliant prisoner that
he very much views you know peaceful
resistance to injustice like civil
disobedience as you know his main
currency in a place like Guantanamo is
the only way he can retain his humanity
and survive as a person so he does that
every step of the way he doesn't he
doesn't he's them particularly
interested in improving his conditions
at Guantanamo earning the privileges
that the prison administration can
bestow on prisoners or revoke at will he
sees it very differently he thinks he
thinks his his approach to it his
philosophy is to you know I guess use
civil disobedience strategy
every step of the way to signal to his
captors that this isn't okay
that you know he's still he's still a
human being that this is still an
injustice he wants to be that constant
reminder to the guards because he
recognizes the guards humanity as one he
feels sorry for many of them because
many of them are 18 19 year olds who
have been sort of trained out of their
better instincts you know they may have
instinctively felt like treating him
humanely but they're being told that
he's this beast this animal and so
they're being trained to treat him and
the other prisoners in the DA man is
dehumanizing fashion and so he wants to
use civil disobedience in addition to
his ability to speak English directly to
the guards as a way to you know help
them retain their humanity as well so I
think that's very much his his approach
and and it's because he's taken that
approach it's because he can't be bought
off essentially that I think the prison
administration of Guantanamo views him
and has viewed him pretty consistently
for years as a threat and which is why
he spent a large a significant portion
of those years in solitary confinement
because they don't want him to be
talking to other prisoners serving as an
example influencing other prisoners but
in the end you know even in that
attitude he isn't unique because to me
one of the most inspiring things about
this hunger strike that started at
Guantanamo and that grew to encompass
the majority of the prison population
this recent year is that it started in
camp six you know I mean camp six is at
the time at least camp six was sort of
the model state-of-the-art facility that
the prison administration of Guantanamo
was showing off to visiting delegations
of journalists reporters foreign and US
dignitaries alike you know they would
take them on tours of vacant cell blocks
on camp six they would show it off they
would say hey this looks like any other
Federal Detention Facility in the United
States and here are all the wonderful
things that the prisoners have access to
and you know they can watch television
they can listen to the radio they can
even play video games they get ice cream
to get food so that that's camp six and
so the fact that the hunger strike began
there of all places to me is what's
particularly inspiring
because it it was it was in this way
that the prisoners were sending a
message to the prison administration to
the US government to the world that it
really doesn't matter what amenities you
may throw in there ultimately this is a
place where an extreme form of violence
is visited on people who have not been
charged and that's that's the violence
of indefinite imprisonment without
charge and regardless of what you do to
the surrounding conditions it's still
going to be lived and experienced as an
injustice and it's still something that
the prisoners will want to resist
through an act of civil disobedience
like a mass hunger strike and it's
simply as unacceptable in 2013 as it was
ten years prior eleven years prior in
2002 when the prison started regardless
of the superficial differences between
the way camp x-ray looked and the way
camp six looked 11 years later
fundamentally it was still the same
place and fundamentally it was still
about indefinite imprisonment without
charge and for those reasons they wanted
to sort of you know cry out for justice
and they did it in a very powerful and
compelling way it wasn't that they were
suicidal I mean a lot of my clients said
you know hunger striking isn't easy
we're doing it because you know we
understand we're gonna pay a price
we understand it's gonna cost us
physically and psychologically and
emotionally and that the administration
is going to crack down on us and try to
break our hunger strike in many
different ways as they have we
understand all of that but it's
important to send the message all the
same and we're not doing it because
we're suicidal or we want to die we're
doing it precisely because we aren't
suicidal when we want to live and we
want to be released and returned to our
normal lives with our families or start
families and many and you know down to
the details I mean many of my clients
would say you know my gesture of protest
my gesture of civil disobedience is not
to accept food for my captors because
it's one of the few things I can choose
it doesn't mean that I would reject tube
feeding
I just reject force feeding when I
reject tube feeding that's being
implemented
unnecessarily brutal way and that was
the same attitude as mr. Joe Harris that
you know he you know he would
voluntarily present for tube feeding he
just didn't want to eat food voluntarily
given from his captors that was his form
of protest but he would voluntarily
present for tube feeding when the prison
administration realized that he was
going to keep this up indefinitely they
chose to escalate they chose to ramp it
up and to make the tube feeding more
painful more violent more rural so that
they could pressure him and hope that
they could get him to a point where he
would abandon his hunger strike which
never worked but they did the same thing
with these prisoners who went on hunger
strike more recently they started to
feeding them and of course feeding them
in the restraint chair in ways doing it
in ways that were humiliating and
painful and uncomfortable again in a bid
to break the hunger strike it's not that
it was necessary it's not that all those
prisoners presented a risk to themselves
or to others but it was just because the
administration made a decision that it
needed to put an end to this massive
hunger strike and that was one way that
they thought they could do it well you
know we're just coming up past an hour
here if we you talked a little bit about
them about camp six and how it now just
looks like any other federal prison
Guantanamo now has this sort of
permanent status it it's it's not just
fences and barbed wire anymore now it's
it's concrete it's there it's in the
ground just to sort of close up here are
we looking at another fifteen ten years
of Guantanamo yeah I mean I certainly I
certainly hope not and it isn't you know
I say that not because I I think
Guantanamo is so uniquely horrible right
I mean I that's not why I'm saying yeah
like I said I mean I think even if the
facility were to shut down tomorrow one
the idea the Guantanamo idea will
survive in many ways and it survived as
a Bagram it survives in the minds of
policymakers it survives in the law
books
you know policymakers know that they
have that option they will inevitably
choose to exercise it again in the
future
as all power is right that's the sort of
irresistible temptation of power it's in
the law books as a sort of a protected
sphere of executive authority that you
can detain people like that Bagram is is
the illustration of that you don't have
to give them process you don't have to
give them habeas even when you do give
them habeas it is virtually meaningless
the DC Circuit Court of Appeals has made
sure of them the Guantanamo setting that
you know when we started post boom at
the end we were winning 75 percent of
these cases at trial despite some pretty
you know
steeply stacked structural odds against
us that you know presumption sort of
sort of the the burden the burden of
proof being a preponderance of the
evidence that was all the government had
to show and even then they were losing
those cases but the court of appeals
stepped in and made it even harder for a
prisoner to win virtually impossible so
despite all of that I mean I think you
know I don't think Guantanamo is is
unique and I think there are many
equally if not more horrible things
going on in our federal prison system
when you look at you know the conditions
that exist in places like Florence
Colorado when you look at the ways in
which certain terrorism trials are
conducted in article 3 courts sort of
bordering on punishing thought crimes
maleeh don't want to exceptional eyes
Guantanamo but at the same time we
should recognize you know some of it's
some of its unique characteristics and
so for my clients at Guantanamo if the
facility were to shut down tomorrow that
would be huge right for them personally
for their families for their communities
there's no questioning that it would
mean the world to them but how
meaningful would it be beyond that I'm
not I'm not so sure like I again I think
I think the at this point the damage is
done the Guantanamo idea is bound to
remain with us for some time to come a
generation if not more I would say and
so the question whether this particular
facility of Guantanamo Bay Cuba is going
to close today in a year in two years
and five and ten
in that perspective becomes somewhat
somewhat inconsequential and that's
that's a you know for someone who's
worked so long on these cases and on
these issues it's it's kind of an odd
thing to say okay thanks
thank you
you